oh speaking of Dolce
speaking out whatever's going on with
Courtney and Kim the tension is brewing
and that tension exploded last night on
the Kardashians what are you going to do
not talk to her forever
that's an option after weeks of the
messy Dolce Gabbana Feud my sister used
my wedding as a business opportunity
she's mad at me live it Kim and Courtney
finally sit down to discuss their drama
I kept on saying I don't want to do this
because it's way too close to Courtney's
wedding I want it to be completely
different and Courtney explains why she
was so hurt because it was my wedding it
really wasn't business for me it was
such a special day I feel like it takes
away from the specialness it feels awful
that my sister used my wedding as a
business opportunity but Kim had some
other thoughts referencing her wedding
to Kanye in 2014. I got married in Italy
am I saying you copied me by getting
married in Italy
performed at my wedding
Andrea Bocelli
who performed at Courtney's wedding
Andrea Bocelli you stole my wedding
country and my wedding performer after
going back and forth the sisters finally
work it out there's nothing else that I
could say but I totally understand I
hear you I'm sorry I'm sorry that my
choices
put us in this situation I'm happy for
the experience but I'm sad and sorry
that that experience hurt you